[Music]
you guys know about lollapalooza right
festival yeah
that's comedy
i it's it's music oh music oh isn't it
like
uh
k rock like always did the concerts
today rock remember k-rock 106.7 have
like the
all the bands yeah yeah yeah so at
lollapalooza there was a security worker
she wanted to go home early
so she did guess what she did she went
home early but she has to find a reason
she set fire to the concert
but as a security person wouldn't you
have to like stay there there oh yeah
that's for the fire department she
really set fire no no no she didn't she
did it hold on although arguably that
might have been a better choice but she
did something
worse i think i see somebody doing
something next to the gate let me go
check that out okay no i think they're
doing something next to the parking let
me go check that out
that's the way to do it oh no i gotta go
on hot pursuit they're going towards my
home
did she
call for a bomb threat
yep she did she even worse than that she
uh she sent a fake text through a text
now
to her supervisor so they don't do a
fake number
and then it says mass shooting at this
time oh we have 150 targets
so basically she was like out of my
jurisdiction because as a security guard
doesn't mean she has to stay longer yeah
yeah because she has to but if it's a
mass shooting threat then they would
have evacuated the place yeah just pop a
balloon
everyone freaks the [ __ ] out now with
any noise you remember remember that
thing in vegas couple couples they broke
a window yeah they break a window and
everyone's freaking the [ __ ] out my
buddy was playing poker he said that
they had to evacuate the whole room
so he left like everyone's leaving like
their backpacks and [ __ ] in there with
like all this cash in there
and they're all just fleeing like
there's an active shooter i saw people
like they tipped over the poker table
and they're like hiding behind it and
[ __ ] i'm like why that shit's kind of
that's not going to stop bullets
just because yeah but maybe they're just
like oh [ __ ] i'm losing so let me
[ __ ] yeah that's a good tactic
okay if these people are able to do
these numbers
with like where does it trace back how
did they text now yeah because what what
happens when you get a mass shooting
threat you have to report it and then
that guy reports it and then this guy
reports and it just keeps moving up the
chain and then the fbi gets it
eventually and then they can go through
text now and then the fbi has the uh
their age they can go through that
exactly they can get ips they can do
this so what they did was you know of
course they're going to come in and ask
questions [ __ ] yeah vpn you [ __ ]
idiot
[Laughter]
everybody gets away with the vpn that's
how you get off work early come on
you're
invisible they go and they you know like
when someone's not really prepared for
you know questioning their lie ends up
being so convoluted it's really
difficult to just [ __ ] your way
through something you didn't really
prepare it's one of those [ __ ] moments
where it's like the fbi is coming ah
[ __ ]
yeah
so she starts saying oh um
my sister actually saw a post on
facebook about it and then they're like
okay can you just screenshot it for us
and then she's like oh there's no
screenshot um so then what she does
she then makes a fake account of this
guy named ben scott
and like writes a post saying massive
shooting at lollapalooza grant park 6
p.m and it's all dated after the event
so then only but she used a vpn this
time when she made it she went incognito
she didn't even do that the fbi simply
just went to the ip address and apple
icloud and it was in her living room
and then when they questioned her she
was like i did it it was me i wanted to
leave work early
how old is she 18 yes
exactly so she didn't realize that the
whole event would shut down
all these people would [ __ ] get
[ __ ] for their money she's like hey
guys we're gonna bump that okay see you
guys tomorrow
yo what happened is just [ __ ] saying
[ __ ] work and walking out i've done that
before yeah you're 18. yeah yeah i'm 18.
you're at a music festival that's why uh
that's why a lot of like news outlets
that are reporting this are are really
highlighting the gen z-ness of this yeah
yeah because it's like [ __ ] if you
don't work leave dude and it's at a
[ __ ] cool spot you got to listen to
me you got a lot you got a lot more life
ahead of you yeah i already got my
friend a wig if they're going to stay
there for the give my friend a wig give
them my security jacket
see ya
but what's gen z about it is that they
didn't just walk out but they had to
call a bomb threat well it's just like
the whole thing about like not wanting
to work and then also being too [ __ ]
like dumb to
understand this like all incorrectly you
know oh is that what they label the gen
z is they don't want to work and also i
think i think i think also it's the uh
the amount of work
that
would have went down
versus the amount of work that exactly
of planning to get out of this yeah you
know that's the stereotype right of lazy
ass gen ziers but then recently i saw a
statistic of 27 percent of jen's ears
they don't take lunch breaks
yeah so they don't take lunch breaks
that means they just continue plowing
out like their their work because
they're like just making bomb threats no
no they're just lazy they're just lazy
if they're doing project-based stuff
then they just they're afraid of like
being fired no no they just want to
finish early oh because it's more like
gig economy you're like project based
you said 27 of the people it's like a
quarter of gen z
they opt out for lunch or they just eat
lunch at their desk while they continue
working so that means out of the five
percent of gen zeros that have a job 24
percent of them skip one
that's very good dude it's so crazy this
i i do believe that because my old uh
the old hotel i used to work at back
home in arizona you know i'll i'll go
back and visit because i still got some
homies that have moved up in the company
or whatever so i'll go say what's up to
them and they say um
a lot of the their new staff they only
want to work half days hmm
yeah they're european of them yeah they
don't want to they don't want to work
full days so part time you just want to
work how do they cover like their
expenses or whatever that's what i'm
saying i don't know i don't know it's
just they all live at home yeah is that
what people do nowadays quite a few of
them they just want to work they don't
they want to work
like half of the day
they don't want to work an eight-hour
shift italians take like a four hour
lunch right yep the cs4 and a half hours
yeah [ __ ] yeah yes no no that's italian
yeah four and a half hour five hour one
siesta is also yeah that italian siesta
the spanish don't do it no yeah dude
yeah so is this real life uh-huh damn
they take long lunches take it from me
look i'm a man look at me this guy's
this guy's dripping in gold yeah you
think he's not taking a four hour italy
dripping with italy facts this guy wow
yeah so this 18 year old security
professional was uh
charged with false terrorism threats
and uh
that's rough dude it is being held 50
000 bail oh
wow
who let her be security yeah
that's their [ __ ] fault is there a
picture of her
yeah uh it's um if she's fine we gotta
save her right that's that's what you're
gonna say right is there a picture of
her in my head i imagine she's like an
18 year old girl who's like five foot
four that's what i'm saying why would
they let an 18 year old girl that's what
i imagine in my head for these events
they it's like hard to find people no
for sure pay [ __ ] and it's uh yeah my
friends got security jobs at a rave
easily would you say my friends got
security jobs at a rave easily and then
we wanted them to do that so we can all
deal okay
can i can i can i say something can we
see what you saw show first and then i
want to say what i want to say okay so
show that that's her
now okay that was going to be my next
guest me too
me too i didn't want to say it i love my
people
i love my people i love you you tried
you could you could have done better i
forgive you
but i was like she black
i just i didn't want to that wasn't the
first thing that came out that was the
first thing that came to my mind
i was picturing a white girl how many
little white girls do you see being
secure
my third guess samoan that was my third
day that was your third guest
shout out to you skip second guess
that was my second guess too samoans are
so big that they could be terrible it
was like a small little mexican girl
that's what i thought in my head no i
was thinking
and i i just third guess was samoan
respectfully
18 yeah man
hey at least she didn't do a [ __ ]
[ __ ] photo in there she's like man i
[ __ ] up
yeah her photo said she [ __ ] up she's
not like doing this smiling thing that
yeah you see sometimes damn so
wait so they're holding her
oh yeah 50 000 bail [ __ ] for that yeah
now that now back to what your statement
earlier do you think you're like oh
she's hot we are we helping her out no
that's what nick would have done
did i gave you my top now
that you didn't you didn't bring that up
i didn't bring that up at all you gotta
save her bro
so they're holding her
i believe so yeah
do you think she's like can i get out
early
and then she calls the bomb threat in
jail
what's my one phone call
her one phone call
is a bomb threat she's got one move damn
it might work it's so crazy the fbi
absolutely hates her
damn that would be a pretty smart move
but no oh man yeah i didn't know they
could track those fake numbers like that
i think at a point they can track
anything like once you're once it
reaches that yeah it's like the cops
can't cuz i've had some homies get got
with those [ __ ]
fake numbers so i'm like
yeah right i don't trust it i'm sure
when that many people are in danger like
for a bombing or like a mass shooting
they're just saying okay everything's
allowed find the [ __ ] person yeah you
know yeah there's one righteously too
right when if someone puts a [ __ ]
mass shooting threat out like they got
to take that to like the 10th degree
they gotta take that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
then at that point what is that called
like threat level [ __ ] red or orange
or some [ __ ] the level omega yeah yeah
or theta depending
hey but hey goes to show that level okay
hey it goes to show it goes to show that
black people still don't do mass
shootings we just we just we just
fake them we fake them we fake them you
call them in you're like the white dude
is coming up here now
he's gonna get you [ __ ]
you